[Music]
she let him hang out to her debit card
and they've been spending all of her
money for the last two years and their
rent on their car payment on everything
here's the full the full stop truth okay
your brother's a thief
and he's not a person of honor
what's up what's up this is john with
the dr john daloni show
the last dr john dolone show ever you
want to know why
[Music]
cause we're going skydiving
right after this show we're gonna get a
car we're gonna drive
not we
me and
dave ramsey a couple other
lunatics
if you think peer pressure ends it for
sure doesn't but i said yes i'm in
eddie
my wife
so
it's my number one fear on the planet on
the planet my number one fear
is jumping out is heights i don't like
being on a ladder i don't do roller
coasters just like as a rule henry cloud
peer pressured me into one the other day
i just don't like i don't like any of
them i did one and i think the moral of
the stories i'm a sucker for peer
pressure
but this time tomorrow
oh man almost to the minute
we'll be tumbling out of a plane
so this is i'm assuming this is i got my
affairs in order i got my will out had a
hard conversation with my 12 year old
i want you all to know it's been fun
it's been super super fun
and i hope we
hope we have another show all right
let's go to chris let's go to chris in
san tan valley arizona what's up chris
how you doing john
uh hey i'm super nervous about jumping
out of an airplane other than that i'm
doing great how are you man
i'm doing good i'd be nervous about
jumping out of an airplane too you know
why because it's insane but good that's
all that's glad we're on the same page
there what's up brother how can i help
ma'am
so recently uh
on my job site i spoke during safety
week about my experience with mental
health and anxiety and i've gotten a lot
of really good responses out of it and
i'm just i'm i want to help these people
and so i'm wondering like what's the
next logical step or what's the next
step that i should do here
um what's the job site man
uh i can't give you the name of it but
it's a it's a very large job site
there's probably
a thousand construction workers oh
construction dude you had a
mental health conversation with
construction workers
yep yep hey let me like
i need you to hear me say this
there are a few people i assign the word
hero to and what you do is heroic
that's it thank you big deal man because
construction's hard and it's got its own
its own culture to it in its own suck it
upness and its own
very man i i'm serious dude that's
inspiring man good for you and so tell
me about how the conversation went
uh it was i've had a lot of
conversations with people afterwards um
there's been at least four people that i
know of that after i got up and talked
about it they reached out to their
company's helplines they went and got
professional help wow there's been a
couple of people that after we talked
one-on-one after that
you know they started taking their
medications again and just a lot of good
positive results people are getting help
and they're helping themselves and
because of this and like i got the
momentum going right now and i've got
the attention on it and i just i want to
keep driving it and keep
trying to find these people that that
need help and
you know we're swapping stories of
of how we're learning to
deal with our mental health issues and
go through it and dealing with life with
this
with these extra issues so
uh
i've thought of starting up maybe a
support group i thought about maybe
trying to figure out a way to keep
pushing the awareness out there and keep
talking about it and i'm just i guess
i'm looking for a direction i need some
help man okay so
they don't make a lot of you man they
broke the mold when you were when you
were came off the line dude so it's an
honor to get to talk to you thank you
for your heart thank you for your
vulnerability your willingness to be
open with folks
and for everybody listening
this is what the world needs right here
is people to stand up in their area in
their group with the with the with the
audience they have which may be an
audience of five pta moms and it may be
an audience of 5 000 construction
workers
rolling their eyes through a safety
training and then all of a sudden
somebody comes up and says hey this
happened to me good for you man this is
this is what the
we do not need a bunch of a bunch more
politicians yelling at each other we
need more chris in the world so thank
you
um all right so i'm gonna tell you a
couple of thoughts i have moving forward
and then i'm gonna challenge you on one
or two things is that cool cool sounds
good all right the first thing is i
wrote down while you were talking set up
a recurring group so same team jinx
right i think that's wise
i think it would be really cool here's
what i'm going to provide you i'm going
to mail you 10 copies for free of
redefining anxiety okay i'm going to
just ship them to you in a box you can
hand out like tic tacs to people okay
and it's it's um really thin it's like
70 or 80 pages it's really thin
and it's about dealing with anxiety and
what it is what it's not how to get your
life back that's the subtitle okay
but it's it's not you don't have to have
a phd to get through it it's a very
simple mental health um awareness book
for folks and then it gives them some
tools so you'll be able to be a resource
there
also if i'm not crazy
this is a particular industry that is um
it's very challenging financially for
some of the the
the tradesmen
and so i'm gonna send you 10
10
ramsey plus subscriptions you know i
work with dave ramsey here and that
includes the financial peace university
so here's what i'm saying a class you
could kick up
is to teach the financial peace class
and offer
um for a year the app and folks for
folks who want to show up to this class
so i'm going to send you 10 of those for
free okay and if you what you're gonna
do is you're gonna teach these folks how
to
how to deal with their money what some
of their challenges are and here's what
happens when you teach someone how to
deal with their money they have to sit
down with their spouse and have a hard
conversation about values and about
togetherness and about doing things
differently and changing family trees
in little tiny wins and paying off debt
and all of those track with getting on
track men with your mental health too
getting connected with other people and
changing your behaviors and changing
your actions and planning and being
intentional all those things right so if
you want to have a class that is hey
we're just going to talk about what's
going on in your life challenges you're
having where you can be heard great
um
if you want to have a class on how to
deal with your money some tactical
things we're gonna have a we're gonna
i'm gonna kick this class up and we're
gonna do that too okay so i'm gonna take
care of you on both of those fronts just
as my gift to you
oh that is amazing thank you you got it
man thank you um so
here's my challenge to you okay
you are feeling the other side of
of being vulnerable which is other
people reach out to you and they say you
made a difference in my life thank you
incredible
and in my life i'll just speak about me
i have to be careful because that is a
powerful intoxicating drug
and what i can do if i'm not careful is
begin looking for where everybody's
going through problems
and i start trying to insert myself and
solve them or come up with another thing
and another thing and another thing
you see what i'm saying and over time it
becomes about me not other people so
here's my challenge to you
the goal now that you have established
this as you've established yourself as a
safe person and you've established this
is something we're going to talk about
in this company and on these job sites
this is just who be is going to be who
we are
is to
create a referral system for a therapist
in your area
ask a local counselors if they'll come
speak once a month at these groups
i go meet um once once a semester i go
meet with the celebrate recovery group
here in town just as a local expert like
hey when i pick your brain about this
and i end up walking away with way more
than those guys did
um
but
bring experts into this conversation who
can facilitate groups who can have some
of these deeper conversations and maybe
partner with some of these construction
companies to say hey we got a group of
guys who are struggling will you guys
pay for x or pay for y
it will help everybody the roi will be
will be more than 150 bucks you're
spending for that one hour for for
donuts and coffee and a therapist to
come give a lecture on fill in the blank
but you see what i'm saying we're gonna
we're going to transition the expertise
from you
to a series of experts and a series of
a system if you will that's going to be
a network of people so people can get
plugged in where they need to get
plugged in does that make
total sense okay am i out to lunch there
or can you go oh yeah i can see that
happening
i could see that happening and i
i think that would be the right
path ultimately okay
um
what are some
key things that have come up in their in
your conversations
a lot of it's been around
a lot of it has been around i'm not sure
if i have issues okay you know you and i
i always
kick people up to either their helpline
or reach out
um
let's have to say another big thing that
keeps coming up is like we're just
swapping stories we're just encouraging
one another and
um
it turns into it do you think i should
reach out to somebody yes i do and then
like a week later i end up having a
follow-up conversation great uh and then
they talk and we talk about it and then
we we kind of share it and it's
been interesting how
with me going through my mental health
experience how much it's connected with
other people going through their mental
health experience because we get each
other almost in a way that
other people don't that's exactly right
yeah
so
one thing that you could do that would
be really powerful is to
make the conversation less about
quote-unquote mental health issues
and more about people getting together
and doing life together
and this is one of those things that i
didn't fully get
until i went down the loneliness rabbit
hole
but
everybody's got challenges in their life
and it's when we try to solve all these
challenges by ourselves
week after week month after month year
after year that they turn into
pathologies over time that's not always
the case people have true mental illness
that's different than mental health
challenges
but
over time it's the accumulation it's the
pile up of this stuff
and you know what can be a great thing
is a softball league
or
a
we all go throw darts on such and such
and you better not miss so we're all
going to text you and harass you and
call you right because you're one of us
places where people can get together and
do life the amount of money the company
where i work
spends on
community interaction just eating
together and playing together is
astounding and as a part of a profit
sharing plan i'm always like dude well
that's a
that's a lot of money we spent
but it's worth it
you see what i'm saying so creating
opportunities for people just to get
together and do what you just said just
talk and hang out
and it's putting a coin in a bank and a
coin and a bank and a coin in a bank so
that some but one day someone's gonna
sit down and go hey
i gotta tell you something just happened
or my daughter's not okay or my wife
left me again right and because you've
built up this this cash reserve over
time and so setting up some places where
y'all could just hang out and talk hang
out and laugh hang out and have some fun
together does that make sense
yes it does i think this is incredible
man
i mean you're talking about entire
culture shift and if you want to get
real brave sit down with the with the
brass with the those the folks who show
up with the clean hard hats and
suits
uh or their the fancy genes
and say i gave this one talk and we've
had a bunch of people come forward
you'll have a real opportunity to help a
lot of people
and if y'all
go beyond hotlines and set up counselors
or maybe offer to pay for food or set up
a space where we can do a
financial peace class or go through some
of those things we all pay the
registration fee for a couple of
softball leagues so we can start doing
some stuff together
and or have a daycare night where they
can go on dates with their spouse with
their you know their wives or their
husbands and we'll watch the kids but
come up with some things that will help
people's lives be a little bit better
you see what i'm saying in the mental
health stuff begins to
not all of it right not all of it
but man you begin to turn the tide on
some of that stuff i think i think
you're a beautiful soul man
what got you
what got you inspired to have this
conversation in the first place
uh
it was just going through the struggles
of it myself and
i really got it into my heart that i
wanted to
get up there and talk to people
so that way anybody that was wondering
you know what's it like to go through
this
what's it like to go get help
like at least kind of give them a
picture of what that might look like and
i really was just i was so focused on
this is an opportunity to help people
but that's where my head was at and so
good man
well i joked later if if i would have
thought all the way through what i was
getting up there to tell everybody
about myself if i would have thought
about that beforehand i may not have
done it
right
that's it's
but the fact that you did it
i mean
you altered people's trajectory man
because you were brave and i'm grateful
for you thank you for stepping into that
gap there
um
yes set up good systems set up a group
set up some tangible let's solve this
problem like money or
oil changes or what i don't know what
the thing is man whatever the thing is
i've i've met with people who started
serving food because they noticed all
their osha complaints were right after
lunch and so the owner of this pipe
fitting company in texas
just started catering organic like
obnoxiously delicious healthy foods and
the osha complaints fell down so
dramatically that they got an
investigation because they were cooking
the books
but it gave the workers an opportunity
to sit down and have lunch together
inside instead of run across and eat at
a gas station and they started eating
healthier foods and then they started
saying hey can my family's come up right
so it changed the system i've seen it
with mental health stuff i've seen it
with play i've seen it with all kinds of
different structures
but it starts with somebody like you
saying not on my watch not anymore i
want my community and i want these folks
lives to be better i want to help so
thank you man thank you so so so much
um stay on the line here we're gonna
send you everything and jenna throw in
um chris i'm gonna send you also my new
book i want you to read it
and if you find it of value i'll send
you a few more copies of that one and um
you can pass that out to the folks as
well as you see fit man and hopefully
this will jumpstart you on your way
if you're listening to this
it starts with you where you are
the problems in our world and the
problems in our government the problems
with our country
are not going to be solved with more
screaming they just aren't they're not
going to be solved with more yelling
they just aren't
they're not going to be solved with more
fists they just aren't
they're going to be solved by standing
up and saying hey this is what happened
to me there's a different way you can do
this
who will join me and that's what chris
did
that's what my friends do and that is
what you can do
go make a difference we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
deloney
all right let's go to margo in chicago
what's up margo in chicago
hi dr john how are you good how are you
it is such a pleasure to talk to you i
stumbled upon you about two years ago
and i'm just
utterly obsessed i guess i could say
that makes my heart feel good thank you
thank you you've made me feel so good in
the past couple of years too i
appreciate all the work that you do
awesome so how can i help you today
so i have a question that kind of
i just need a hell a little bit help
sorting out
long story short um
i'm trying to help my mom
feel better and not be so brokenhearted
and
myself as well by some major disrespect
my brother and his wife had caused
within the last
three weeks or so okay um can i
interrupt you real quick yep yes please
does your mom want to feel better
yeah for sure
does she recognize that something has
happened to her that was wrong
yes okay all right cool i just want to
make sure you are trying to solve a
problem that your mom didn't think
needed solving okay
so what'd your brother do
long story short um just some like back
history so it's always been me my mom
and my brother since
20 years now my dad died when i was 16
and he was eight so it's just been the
three of us you know helping each other
taking care of each other always at each
other's back we've always had a very
strong family bond it's been a beautiful
thing um i considered him one of my best
friends and so forth
um so about
four years ago i bought a house and i
told my mom and my brother come live
with me my mom
is older and retired and has been
retired since my dad died and uh i'm
like it's time for me to you know take
care of her
so she's living with me and then my
brother came to and i had a beautiful
furnished basement that i just let him
live in
because he's a good kid and
um
okay so speed up the process a little he
ended up meeting this girl
and um they ended up getting married and
okay that's fine you know do your thing
but ever since i've been married it's
like she just keeps trying to take him
away and away and further away and i
just don't understand why i feel like
she's come from a very
family oriented
place i don't understand why all of a
sudden
that's going on so my point is
he they've been very distant anytime we
have an event or a birthday party for my
kids i have two kids and they're
obsessed with them
as they should be and
it's just so disappointing they won't
come they'll come through obviously
um they won't show up at all and it's
not really like
my brother
so i've had conversations a couple of
times like what is going on like you
guys can we just get it together and
i mean you guys are 20 something years
old you aren't children anymore like if
you don't want to come just let me know
i said it kind of sit here and plan my
tools around my kids naps or activities
or whatever may need to be done they
don't have any then or anything like
that so
you know i maybe right for them to
understand that
christmas time came and um
after christmas
they i had tried reaching out to my
brother a couple times he wasn't
answering she wasn't answering i was
starting to get worried
and so i had just sent a text and said
listen if you guys don't respond i'm
gonna do
a wellness check on you somebody respond
to me and then finally my brother called
me and i could just tell in his tone
something was wrong i'm like what is
going on
and he just said he's like i'm
frustrated he's like every time we like
your house he's like me and monsieur
that's his wife always get into a fight
i'm like about what he's like because
she just she doesn't feel welcomed she
just doesn't feel comfortable mind you
dr jean every time this girl comes over
she's on her phone from the minute she
walks in to the minute she leaves
so
hey margo i i can tell in just in this
phone call
you don't like her
i don't but it's because of all this
drama i know i don't know how wrong i
have put it all aside it's been very
nice for the girl i promise no i know i
know i know i know i didn't want to get
into a fight with my brother about her i
know i know that you are nice to her i
don't think that at all i don't think
you're disrespectful at all
but i can tell you don't like her
and it sounds like you had a very clear
picture of what you wanted this thing to
look like this thing being y'all's
family
and
i guess i just don't understand why we
can't all just be together and celebrate
holidays and it's not what it is
what you're asking for is why can't
everybody's life be how i want it to be
why can't i have a picture of how i want
my life to look and why can't everybody
just live into my picture
and
it's normal for somebody to get married
and get distant
it doesn't mean it's right doesn't mean
you love it you clearly miss your
brother
but it doesn't mean that it's the wrong
thing
you see what i'm saying
you've made this
it's not it's not a rejection of you
margo
it feels like you're taking this really
personally
well
i kind of am because
now
a couple of weeks ago
i had called him and i hit
the holidays
and i need help with my mom she's very
her mobility is not the greatest things
are getting difficult for me i've got
two a two-year-old and a four-year-old
that i'm also taking care of okay
is your mom still living with you now
yeah she is
taking care of her it's just it's
becoming a little bit harder so all i
asked for
because i'm trying to sell my house
was for her to maybe whisper him to
maybe hang out with her saturday and
sunday so i could sleep for work because
i work
friday saturday sunday
7 p.m to 7 00 am who are you a nurse
yeah
awesome
and so i called them and it was like hey
you know
i was just wondering if you could help
me out with mom
i'm putting up the house for sale i was
like it would be a little bit easier
if
you could hang out with mom for a few
hours that way edwin who's my boyfriend
could take the two kids and he could go
do his thing
and maybe you could hang out with mom
for a little bit that way i could just
sleep because i'm not going to have my
boyfriend take care of my mom and the
two kids sure sure so so get to what
happened so what happened
so he's like okay yeah for sure i'll say
go home talk to him and say
call me back and let's get a game plan
so he called me backstage with me
and he
already i could tell he was just like
i don't feel like it's an appropriate
time to help you and i'm like
but it's more for her like it's not
really for me i'm like i need help for
mom i didn't ask you to babysit my kids
didn't have to borrow money i didn't ask
for anything for myself like i just
needed help with mom so your brother
didn't show up your brother didn't show
up for you he didn't show up for your
mom
right so then
my mom saw something on tv and she said
could you buy me this i was like yeah
i'll buy it for you so i went to go buy
it and come to find out
her debit card client
and my mom usually i don't know why but
she let him hang on to her debit card
and they've been spending all of her
money for the last two years and their
rent
on their car payment on everything in
their
world
you know took screenshots i had to
confront them i haven't heard a word
from them obviously you're not going to
embarrass hell tell me how i can help
how i can help
i just don't know what i can do to tell
my mom because my mom keeps trying to
call him he's not answering and i'm like
mom you're just gonna have to leave it
alone and she just doesn't understand
why okay
here's here's here's the full the full
stop truth okay
your brother's a thief
yeah and he's not a person of honor
yeah
and you are gonna have to grieve that at
some point okay right now
you need to have your mom move the bank
account into your into your name
okay good so he's cut off right
yeah
until he decides
that relationship is is
over it's on it's it's
kaput
okay
any sort of calling or cathartic like
i'll tell you or confrontation
that won't make you feel better and
it's not gonna happen the way you think
it's gonna happen
okay okay
so the best you can do right you could
call the police and report him as a
thief
they would probably he's gonna say mom's
told me i could and she's gonna say i
don't remember or i don't think so but
she's not gonna put her own son in jail
and so you can call the police you can
do that um
but here's the deal
your brother's a thief and he stole from
his own mother
yeah and it's gross and it's sad and
it's heartbreaking and i hate that y'all
had to go through this
the question is more
how are we going to move forward
you particularly moving forward not with
him not in your life
you're going to have to let that picture
and go really really sorry
me too
to shave
it's such a shame
but listen that anger
you've heard the story that line but
i'll give it to you again being as angry
as you are at him
is just like poisoning yourself hoping
he gets sick
yeah
all you're doing you know all you're
doing is creating chaos in the home of
your four and two-year-old don't give
them that yeah i don't want to i don't
want to okay so here's what i want you
to do
i want you to write two different
letters to your brother neither of which
you're gonna send okay
the first letter is a letter of anger a
letter of rage
here's what you did
the second letter is a letter of
forgiveness and here's all forgiveness
is
it doesn't mean what he did was right it
doesn't mean that he will ever step foot
in your home again he'll ever have
access to your mom or mom's money again
none of that
if you think about what he did he came
and threw a giant cinder block into your
lap
and said you know what sister you deal
with this
and all forgiveness is is you standing
up and saying i'm not gonna carry your
brick anymore
okay okay free yourself of that
and i know i'm making it sound way
easier than it is it's gonna be hard
it's gonna be brutal you're gonna have
to grieve the fast to the fact that your
brother
is not a person of character
i just threw a lot at you
tell me how you're feeling
no i mean i feel better actually just
getting it off my chest i mean there was
like a lot of different
aspects to
how i was feeling and i feel like i
in my own and i guess
feel just very disrespected because i've
done a lot for him and
for him to not even
margo
you are deeply deeply
disrespected you were
grossly so
i'm just getting tired
yeah i'm trying to hear them home one
day through friday with my kids which
you know i'm grateful for that i work
friday saturday and sunday and then i'm
worried about my mom and he won't help
me
listen listen listen listen
i wrote down right here on my notes
exhausted
have you been a nurse for the last few
years in chicago
unfortunately yes yes you have been
living in the in the depths of the
furnace of hell
and by the way you know we should do
let's
let's have a second kid that'll be let's
do that right
and
mom's uh
falling apart right underneath our very
eyes
right
so none of those things we can change
what we can change is
okay brother's a variable it's out of
the equation
where are other places i can get help
i can get support
are there city resources are there
government resources are there work
resources
is dad in the picture
oh no i guess boyfriend's in the picture
yeah okay or is he the kid's
dad yeah yeah yep okay
um
he can take a role a more a prominent
role right so here's what we do let's
stop thinking about what brother's not
doing every time and let's start
focusing on the solutions because you're
right you're exhausted and you cannot
keep running like you're running
is that fair
that's fair
so i want you to build a wellness
strategy for marco
what does a world look like where margot
gets sleep
what is a world where margot gets to
laugh every once in a while
where margot
yes she loves her kids but she gets a
night or two off from them
where margot goes on dates again
where margot gets help with mom
hear what i'm saying
i do
will you pro will you
will you love margot enough to build
that world
yeah absolutely and i know you can't
afford it and i didn't have time to do
it
i know all those things but i'm telling
you is
you gotta you gotta figure that out
whether it's trading with some of your
fellow nurses whether it's telling
boyfriend hey
we're not going to play house anymore
we're getting married and you're going
to have to get another job whatever i
don't know what it looks like
but if he's gonna be in he needs to be
all in
and then he's gonna be helping his
mother-in-law too
but you're trying to hold all this
together yourself and you can't
you can't
write the two letters to your brother
[Music]
and put them in a fire pit put them in a
shredder get rid of them
[Music]
commit to not carrying that stuff
anymore your brother's a thief he stole
from you stole from your mom
and then be about creating a world where
margot
is well
you've been running for three years now
it's time
it's time
that'll be a great gift to your kids
to your mom
and it'll be a great gift to you
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and they'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's go to angela on the
streets of laredo what's up angela
hello dr john how are you well i'm
partying that's not true i'm not
partying i'm hanging out what's up what
are you up to
well i'm just getting out of work right
now heading home and it's about 100 plus
degrees here so
i had a fan in front of me right now but
jenna couldn't hear me so i had to turn
it down too hot
super hot over here
you got that right all right so what's
up
well i
am about i'm in my mid 40s and i was
married for almost 20 years and then i
was divorced
and uh what happened now i'm in then oh
that's gonna take another call oh okay
all right all right
uh in in long long story short my
ex-husband uh committed a federal crime
and i had to separate from him
that is hey you know what wrapped up
right there with a bow on it that's all
we need to talk about exactly all right
exactly um and i burned the letter
already so you know
i'll hit the nail on the head on that
part let me tell you
good sorry so
we've turned the letter we're on to the
new one right um to the new one correct
and um he's a wonderful wonderful man we
have been in a relationship for almost
four years
the problem is that i am a social
butterfly and i enjoy going out i enjoy
meeting new people
i enjoy dancing and
he doesn't and we went to a gathering
about a week and a half ago and i had to
prep him for it so to speak
and
we were going to sit with some friends
of ours and turns out the table was
short was smaller rather
rather smaller than we thought
so we wound up sitting with strangers
which i was fine with but he was he was
very nervous about it and he said i
think i want to leave and he said but
i'm not um but i think i want to and i
was like you're okay don't worry about
anything and you know the night
continued but later on he did tell me
you know like there's times that i do
want to just get up and go
um and
i
feel like this is a very serious
relationship i wouldn't have given it
three years of my life if i didn't think
it was
um but what i'm worried about is how do
we continue because
i love being social and he is a
he's a big introvert he's the only male
child and he's got about six sisters so
exactly i feel like he
no never had the chance to speak he was
always around a bunch of girls
um all right so
let's take introvert and extrovert off
the table
okay here's why
those labels end up
conflating a lot of things giving a lot
of excuses and a lot of blah blah blah
let's take that off i agree okay let's
go down to very simple
here's what i need to be in a
relationship with you
and vice versa
tell me what you need to be in
relationship with me
and what we are going to do
is spend the rest of our lives working
to meet the other person's needs
so here's an example in my house
um
i take silence as rejection i don't know
why i just do
when i walk by a person in new york city
on the sidewalk and i say hey what's up
and they look at you like crazy or worse
they just act like you didn't say
anything
my first thought is what did i do what's
wrong hey let's go talk i'll buy the
first round are you okay right that's
just my body takes off that way
when that happens in my home
it sets off some sort of rejection alarm
that i fully don't understand
and you mirror that with my wife likes
silence in the morning
don't talk
can we just wake up slowly and quietly
and read and write and have coffee and
watch the sun come up
and listen to the birds and i want to
talk and sing and have conversations
let's have a party hey let's get the
band together
let's have a house party at 5 45 a.m
that is me right
so what we had to do in our house
is
sit down and say what do you need
and i said and it was hard for me to say
this because i'm supposed to be a big
tough texas male
i said i need you to say good morning
and just give me a hug
i need that anchor point in my day if i
don't get that anchor point i'm all over
the place
and she said
done
and
she needs
space in the mornings that is just hers
for her to slowly on ramp the day
that includes writing and reading
and meditating and reflecting and all
those things
and so i moved my workout time from the
evening to the mornings
that automatically boom an hour
separation right there
and so in them you see what i'm saying
so we both sat down and said we love
each other
and i have this need and you have this
need how can we work to make each to
meet each other's needs and i had to
learn i can't have a disco at 5 45
and she had to learn she can't have
complete and utter silence because she
doesn't live in a monastery
and both of us made peace so what i'm
telling you is this what i would love to
see you and this guy who might be your
your forever guy
sit down and say okay we've been
together for three years
you have some needs that i'm not meeting
or that are new or that are changing or
whatever
what needs do you have and vice versa
here's the needs i have
i need to go dancing once or twice a
month i need that and i want that to be
with you
i need you to be seen in public i need
you to smile in public i need to have
this joy out there
and he might say i need silence too
and so i agree cool i am going to make
peace with sitting down on the couch and
snuggling up with a pizza and whatever
the thing is you hear what i'm saying
correct yes
so let's approach it with what do you
need
and what are you willing to do what are
you willing to invest in this thing
and he might tell you i need you to
never ask me to go dancing again because
i'm never going
and i would tell you don't marry that
guy
because hey cause that's not about
dancing that's about him looking you in
the eye and saying i don't care what
your needs are mine are more important
i want someone who says i hate dancing i
don't like it it makes me feel exposed
and i'm gonna go figure it out
which is exactly what happened the other
night he said i wanted to leave but i
stayed because
i wanted i knew you were having fun and
i love you and so i wanted to stay
because you were happy excellent but he
did tell me the other day he was you
know dying on the inside that entire
time
at some point
that's a choice
at some point he can choose like
here's a great example i agreed to go i
was talking about this beginning of the
show i agreed to go skydiving tomorrow
with dave ramsey a couple of friends
it's my number one fear on the planet
i'm about 98 sure this is the last phone
call i'll ever take in my whole career
right now this is it well you picked a
great one i did i got really lucky
um
but i said i would go and so when i said
i would go i now have two choices
i can
go all in and be like dude this is going
to be crazy and fun and i'm going to
smile about it i'm going to be like ah
or i can curl up in a ball and be like
we're going to die we're going to die
we're going to die i get to choose which
one of those we're going to do
that i'm going to do you know what i
mean i get to live into the reality that
i've accepted
correct okay
he is ex he has chosen you
and you are a person that goes dancing
and so since she's going to be with
somebody who goes dancing that means
he's going to go dancing
and then he gets to choose am i going to
be dead inside
or am i going to sneak off and i'm going
to start taking dance lessons or maybe
if you offered him i need to go dancing
and i know you're uncomfortable i signed
us up for for dance lessons and we're
going to do that instead of going to the
gym it's going to be good at work out
blah blah blah we're going to do that
together see what i'm saying
yes
but yeah
i've talked a lot
come get back to this
what are your needs
and here are my needs and how can i work
to
help you meet your needs so that you can
work and help me meet my needs and we're
just going to make a loop an infinity
loop over and over for the rest of our
lives and those needs are going to shift
and change and move so we're going to
check in every couple of months every
couple of um every six months uh once
twice a year we're going to keep
checking with it what are your needs now
what do you need in this season what do
you need in this season i'm gonna make
that happen
and if he says i'll go dancing but i'll
be dead inside
some of that is just texas nonsensical
bravado you know that you know yes but
some of that is a choice and maybe you
say i need you to choose
that when we go dancing
that you're gonna have fun make that
choice for me
choose to have fun i can't choose to
have fun yes you can
you can
i've ended up in places where i'm like
i'm just gonna cut loose and i end up
acting like a clown and it's funny and
it's silly and i have a great time and i
go home and i'm grumpy about it it was
not that bad
you know what i mean
yes
and i've also sat at tables and thought
i would rather set my face on fire than
continue sitting here
and that is a choice that i make
not the table
you got it see what i'm saying yes and
you
angela
may have to spend
a couple of nights watching movies or
laying low
or saying you need some quiet
rejuvenating time go spend time hunting
with your buddies
go spend time fill in the blank go work
on your dad's car whatever the thing is
i don't know what he's into go play
don't don't play golf absolutely don't
play golf i don't know what he's into
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna support you in those
endeavors because i know you need that
and when you get a couple who tries to
meet each other's needs out meet each
other's needs
and he's trying to outmeet your needs
you're trying to outmeet his needs
that's a marriage that is built to last
that is a love that will continue and
continue despite everything in in
because of everything
that's one that's going to keep going
and keep going and keep going
because it's not about what about me and
it's not about i need you to it's about
how can i meet your needs so that you
can meet mine
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
we are back team
if this is it
i want to tell you it's been fun
you might ride or die
not my flat of the plane or anything but
thank you all for all of your hard work
and you don't look amused at all
this is a huge deal
lucky for me we've got nate and nate
said you know what the song of the day
should be
said nope
and they handed me this incredible john
mayer's tune it's called gravity
it's what's gonna pull me from the
heavens
into a puddle onto the onto the ground
it's called gravity and it goes like
this
it's working against me
and gravity wants to bring me down
oh i'll know that tomorrow
well i'll never know what makes this man
with all the love that his heart can
stand dream of ways to throw it all away
you mean like just jumping out of an
airplane
gravity is working against me and it
wants to bring me down twice as much
ain't twice as good and can't sustain
like one half could
it's wanting more that's gonna send me
to my knees
gravity
stay the hell away from me
gravity is taking better men than me
just keep me where the light is
ah please keep me where the light is i
hope to see you soon take care
coming up on the next episode i more
want to make sure that our relationship
is strong enough to where when we bring
a child into the world that it's in a
good place i can imagine if somebody's
hinting around hey i'm 30
and i'd love to have a family with you
and we've been married for two years and
you're like well
kind of have this
thing about what the
it's gonna look like i want to make sure
we're strong that's telling her
i'm still trying you out and he pretty
much just lives in his bedroom
we rarely see him
and he hasn't gone to any counseling and
my paralyzation comes from the fact that
i'm just so afraid i'm going to say the
wrong saying the wrong thing and cause
him to feel like he's a burden to us and
then cause him to take his own life i'm
sorry this is happening
you love that boy huh
well very much
[Music]